la ministre des transports était
accompagné d'un vice président de la
commission européenne pour découvrir
certains prototypes de l'institut vd
comme que ce soit la voiture électrique
qui se recharge toute seule en roulant
ou cette voiture blanche prototype du
transport à la demande
autonome puis quand la mission aura été
acceptée par le poste de commande
centralisé va venir se positionner ici
qui a beaucoup de territoires dans
lequel il faut tout simplement répondre
aux besoins des gens qui n'ont pas le
permis de conduire ou qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de conduire une voiture et
je pense que des solutions de ce type là
demain dans des zones peu denses
ça pourra tout à fait répondre à cet
enjeu de la mobilité pour chacun en
pleine assises nationales de la mobilité
cette visite visait aussi à saluer le
travail de l'institut versailles et vd
comme depuis sa création il ya trois ans
l'institut est devenu un leader européen
dans la recherche de solutions
innovantes pour les transports financée
par des acteurs de l'automobile les
différentes collectivités vd com dispose
aujourd'hui d'un budget annuel de 30
millions d'euros
les axes dans lesquelles on se dirige
sont clairement les axes qui sont
poussés à la fois par la france et par
l'europe c'est des axes de mobilité avec
plusieurs modes en même temps c'est des
axes d'efficience énergétique
c'est aussi des axes dans lequel le
véhicule autonome apporte un vrai plus
sur le transport à la demande pour
poursuivre son développement vd com
prévoit de s'installer l'an prochain
dans de nouveaux locaux à versailles
satory